okay it's uh my pleasure to introduce
the guest lecture in the fin algorithmic
monetary theme albertus will be coming
us logic and random structures thanks
thanks so I'll tell you about logic and
random structures and maybe I should be
calling it random graphs because mostly
I'll be talking about graphs maybe at
the end we'll say something about
structur but most of the focus will be
will be graphs so here is the random
graph papers the classics we have Eros
Reni and Gilbert so Gilbert is not as
well known but many people do know the
story that Gilbert was the one who
introduced the so-called GNP model where
you throw edges in the random graph
independently with probability P each
Edge appears independently of the others
in the a those reny model instead what
they were considering is the uniform
distribution over all graphs with
exactly M edges or or n they they were
using capital N it turns out that these
two models uh for most of the
interesting things happen to be
equivalent and very often one switches
from one model to the other uh in order
to prove certain things and then apply
some general theorems that allow you to
to go from one place to the other so for
us we will focus mostly on this model
which I'm going to Define now but before
I do that I want to a little bit of
History I wanted to know why why did
these people consider random graphs and
well Gilbert was working in B
Laboratories and then you start reading
and it starts like a mathematical paper
so let N let N points numbered one to n
be given blah blah blah but then you go
a bit further down and there is this
paragraph you cannot really read it but
I can read it for you and it says as an
application imagine the end points to be
end telephone Central offices and
suppose that each pair of offices has
the same probability blah blah blah so
really he I don't know if he had this
motivation but at least he had this
written here maybe to please his boss I
don't really know so in both cases they
were studying the probability of the
random graph being connected and uh
however the focus of Gilbert was more in
the case where P was a constant and
therefore you have a dense random graph
and eror were more interested in the
case where uh the the number of edges is
very sparse is is very small so
something like n l it's not very small
but relatively small and these two
things will be actually leading through
my talk and so I will talk about them
when it comes the time so what are
random graphs and what are limit
probabilities how do we Define them so
you have let's say GN is the set of all
indirected graphs and we're considering
labeled graphs with labels 1 to n and G
is the union of all graphs on on these
vertices now G and P is a discrete
probability space which is defined for
because it's finite you can Define it on
all points and then extend it by sums so
every graph gets this probability of
appearing so P to the number of edges
independently each Edge appears with
probability p and each non Edge has
probability 1 minus P of of being a non
Edge and then when you have a set of
graphs you define each probability to be
the sum of the graphs that are in the
set now when you have a set of graphs
you want to look at the limiting of
these probabilities and then you look at
the MU of P we Den note this as the
limit of all these uh probabilities at
the finite stages when the limit
exists so what are questions that we can
ask uh in this model and what what Eros
reny and Gilbert asked the things we can
ask is well for which piece for which
properties of graphs does this limit
actually exist so this is a first
question you want to ask then what kind
of shapes this function so this gives
you for every n it gives you a
probability which is the probability
that the random graph with vertices
satisfies the property what shapes this
function can have that's another
question you want to ask H what
convergence rates do you have can you
answer these sort of things what are the
Almost sure properties of uh the random
graph Almost sure would mean that a
property that holds with probability one
as n goes to Infinity this we're looking
at asymptotic combinatorics so we're
looking at the asymptotic
limit um how do we compute the
probability the limiting probability
when when it exists and for us what
we're interested is can logic shed uh
light on such questions and if you look
at the literature on random graphs uh
there is always some logical component
behind because the properties that
people are interested are very uniform
usually they are
definable I mean they are certainly
uniform there is one exception that I
will talk about in the
end um so they are they are defined by
some finite sentence of some language
and the other hand they are also usually
Clos on isomorphisms so it makes sense
to talk about what is their logical
complexity what does it take to Define
them and therefore it makes sense to ask
what logic can can say about it so the
first part of the talk I will talk about
the dense case the dense case means that
the probability is fixed it's going to
be a constant it's one half it could be
any other constant the same Theory would
go through what this means is that the
number of edges is approximately half uh
on average right I mean it's half of the
number of possible
edges uh and you have so therefore you
have n Square edges most more or less so
here's a basic tool that we want to use
when we want to do counting and
probability which is the inclusion
Exclusion Principle and this is a very
basic thing we learn
in kindergarten I guess and but it turns
out that we never need the full power of
this this is quite powerful if you use
it in if you're able to use it
completely you only usually only need
the union bound or the first moment as
it's sometimes called and the the second
moment is often enough to get all your
estimates that you need so these are
called sometimes the first moment and
the second moment so you notice that
this is an upper bound this is a lower
bound and in fact I need two terms and
in two consecutive terms sandwich the
right sandwich the right uh the right
set size of the set so one thing is that
when you study random graphs you realize
that this is happening you're using
these things over and over again and
mostly all when you especially in the
dense case you don't use many more
things I mean basically this is all you
use so one by analyzing what logic can
say about random graphs we will find out
that this is also the only thing we need
and it will be a justification why it
happens that in the theory of random
graphs this is always the thing we're
using so let's see an example several
examples and let's see our point at the
end how it is uh Justified so let's
compute this very simple probability All
Points have at least one neighbor well
let's look at this event the for a fixed
n and a fixed vertex what is the
probability that youu doesn't have
neighbors well you have n minus one
candidates neighbors and if it's not a
neighbor you have oneus probability and
these are independent events so this is
the probability of you not having any
neighbors now some vertex does not have
neighbors this is just a union right uh
of these events and therefore you can
bound it by the first moment and so
these are n times the same
probability so you can see now that if p
is a fixed constant then this is an
exponential function this is a
polinomial function so this goes to zero
so the probability that some vertex does
not have neighbors is goes to zero so
the probability that all points have at
least one neighbor goes to one by the
way here I can illustrate the use of the
second me moment if if we use the lower
bound using the second moment then it's
not difficult to compute these
quantities and then what you get is a
very good approximate because this
quantity here goes to goes to zero very
quickly so you get a good approximation
of this very simple
case I'm going to do three examples
because they are illustrative and they
will be useful later the second and the
third one will be a bit faster so all
pairs have a common
neighbor you let's say three vertices
are different let's say they are all
edges this is P Square probability P
Square now the probability that you and
V do not have a common
neighbor well not having a common uh
that W is not a common neighbor is this
probability and you have n minus two
possibilities for different vertices and
these are independent events so you get
that then you apply again the union
bound you get a polinomial function an
exponential function something that goes
to zero so we get what we
want so these are examples of what we
call extension properties and in fact
you can ask can we go further since in
the case P equals 1 12 you have a
symmetry between edges and non-edges you
can ask actually more general questions
like this so let's say the RS extension
property is the following you want to
see that every R set and every s set
there is a point that is fully connected
to everything in R and it's fully
disconnected from from everything in s
okay so green is supposed to mean Edge
and red is supposed to mean non
Edge so this is the RS extension
property and it's not even clear that
there are finite graphs that satisfy
this but if you do this very simple
counting they do I mean most of the
graphs actually satisfy this for fixed
RNs so let's do it again very simple
computation so you have a set of size r
R and a set of size s listed as a topple
what is the probability that all these
things are edges and all these things
are non-edges you have P to the r 1
minus P to the
S so now what is the probability that u
and v fail to have an appropriate
extension so an extension of the right
kind well this is the probability that a
particular candidate fails and you have
this many possibilities and they are
independent events because they involve
dis joint edes so now you take the Union
bound uh what is the probability that
some r or S tles fail to have an
appropriate extension you get a
polinomial function followed by an
exponentially decreasing function so
this goes to zero so we proved that with
high probability for every fixed
RNs uh the graph is going to have this
RS extension property so it means that
any two sets can be extended in any way
you like and the set of size
RNs so this is the con the the the
concept of K extendable graphs that was
studied
uh studed studied by Gan as a property
of of graphs and he was looking at the
infinite graph that satisfies the RS
extension properties so let's say that
the graph is K extendable if it
satisfies the RS extension for all RNs
that add at most K minus one it means
that any K minus one points can be
extended H to another one in the way you
like so what we just proved is that the
prod propy of K extendability goes to
one and that's because you have finitely
many for every fixed K you have finitely
many of these they all have probability
one so the conjunction has also
probability one because it's a finite
number so these were the notion of
extendability was studied by Gman in the
context of uh infinite models and he
wanted to Define measures on infinite
models and but then these two groups of
people f making a person one group of
one person they realized that uh this
property holds Gan did not state this
explicitly it's not clear that he
knew and but this is true and they made
a use of it so what use do they make of
it they proved the 01 law by the way
these these people here uh of course
these are four Russians and fing was in
America so this is one more example of
the separation between East and West so
they were not aware of their work uh
Fagan was a work of of Gan and he States
explicitly that it doesn't seem to
follow from gan's work that this is the
case Andreas has a paper
later yeah we we talked about that yeah
Andreas has a paper as well on that they
also proved
that all right so so the Z1 law uh this
is the use they made the Zer States the
following it's very simple condition it
says that if you have a first order
definable property of graphs then the
probability is either zero or one so
it's that
simple so this answers already quite a
lot of the questions we had in the dense
case it was what properties have limits
well all first order properties have
limits and what are the limits well they
are zero or one they even it even
answers things about the rate of
conversion and this is also a
paper and we're actually follow from
from the proof that I'm going to give
now so this is fagin
proof we said the following so let's
look at um well first of all k
extendability for fix K is a first order
formula for every RNs points there is a
w that extends so now you take this set
of sentences you take the sentence that
says that the relational structure is a
graph the binary relation symmetric and
reflexive and you put all the extension
axioms as they're
called all right so this is a theory and
this has a accountable model there are
two ways to see this one is you build
one explicitly and there are several
ways to do build one one is by extending
finite sets and keep adding elements
until uh you take the limit and this
will satisfy it or you can do it
explicitly as well there are explicit
constructions quite simple to do there's
another way which is by using
compactness because we just proved that
these sentences have probability one any
finite set of this is going to have uh
probability one and therefore we'll have
uh a finite model so every finite set is
satisfiable so the whole thing is
satisfiable by compactness so this has a
accountable model and in fact this
model is actually unique up to
isomorphism and this is exactly what Gan
was doing Gan studied the Rog graph and
uh he realized that uh the set of axioms
imply that the theory of the r graph is
omega categoric
all all uh models of the theory are
going to be isomorphic so in particular
it means that if they are isomorphic the
theory is complete so it means that for
every formula
either um either it's a consequence of t
or it's or the negation is a consequence
of T and now you apply compactness to
this you say well uh for every Fe there
is a finite t z that either implies five
or it implies not
five all right so but now this is a
finite set of things that have
probability one so this is going to have
probability one so you're left with the
conclusion that we wanted which is that
the probability of five is at least that
of this and the probability of this is
one so the probability of this is one or
the probability of this is one which
means that the negation so five has
probability zero done this is the proof
it's very simple very nice and very
clear on the other hand this proof
doesn't say how do you compute comp the
probability how do you compute
me uh but it's a very nice uh Excursion
into the infinite to conclude something
about the finite then 01 laws are really
a property of uh uh a notion of finite
structur and in fact it will reappear
later this kind of argument if I have
time to go through one of the
proofs all right so how further can we
go we have this first order logic and we
want to go to richer languages to
express more properties we already know
from an new uh talk that uh connectivity
for example is not first order definable
so for example Gilbert paper which was
about connectivity in the G&P model for
constant P will not be explained by this
the probability of of uh of being
connected so let's go to richer
languages and just a little reminder
from anus talk um let's recall that this
denotes indistinguishability by K
variable sentences so these are
sentences of first order formula that
can be written of first order logic that
can be written with at most ke variables
and in distinguishability means that
they satisfy the same formulas
sentences and also from uh the lectors
this morning we know that inflationary
fixo logic so everything that is
definable in inflationary fixo logic uh
will be closed under this equivalence
relation for some large of
K
and K will be basically the number of
variables it takes to write this
inflationary fix point
formula now a crucial observation is the
following we were looking at the models
of uh of the K extension
aims and it turns out that
um well if you look at all of them then
you get a single model which is the r
graph but if you look at the finite
number of them or in particular single
one two graphs are K extendable then
that is enough to guarantee that these
two graphs are going to be
indistinguishable by K variable
sentences and there is a very simple
argument for that which is based on
the game characterization of this
equivalent relation so remember that two
things are
indistinguishable distinguishable if
duplicator has a winning strategy in the
K
game and now so let's see how we can use
the fact that they are extendable up to
K to design this winning strategy and
then we'll be done so how is the winning
strategy working well at any time in the
at any moment in the game we have at
most K Pebbles on the board right in
fact less than K because we're
considering the case where spoiler now
puts one more Pebble and duplicator has
to reply to that knowing that he already
has a partial isomorphism between the
Pebbles that were before now he has to
reply to something that spoiler pebbled
and he has to preserve
isomorphisms that's very easy I mean the
new point is connected to some points
and disconnected from others so by the K
extendibility remember we have at most K
minus one things on the board we have
such a witness in the other graph so
duplicator will choose that and we
continue the game and this can go on
forever as long as there are at most K
pbls on the
board this is a very crucial and simple
observation is saying that extendability
up to K guarantees in distinguishability
by K variable Logics ah but then this is
very good because it has the following
Coral is well the 01 law for first order
logic
um okay and and also for inflationary
fix Point logic and in fact for any
class that is Clos under the K
equivalence relation for some K so why
is that it suffices to prove the last
one because the last one implies the
others this one will be close under K
equivalence and this one even more so
why is the last one true well suppose
you have a property that is Clos under
this k equ
relation now this means that the
property is made of a union of
equivalent
classes but now there is one huge
equivalence class that has probability
one which is the one made of the graphs
that are K
extendable right so there are two
possibilities either this contains the
equivalence class of the K extendable
gra the K extendable graphs or it
doesn't if it does contain it then it
has probability one it has a huge
equivalence class modeling the property
and if it and if it doesn't contain it
then the complement contains it right
because it's close under equivalence Rel
equivalence relation so we get the 01
law so this is a very simple proof now
again and it's it's a different it's
different because it goes It goes beyond
and it's it's not using the infinite
graph this is also quite quite
important so the history here is of
course the 01 law was proved by glebsky
and others and fagin then for
inflationary fix Point logic uh this was
proved by Blas Gage and Ken by a
different
argument which
uh was
more it was kind of a Quantified
elimination argument which was more
similar to this one maybe I'll say a bit
more now and then the last one was
generalizing the others was proved by
colitis and fi and they were stating
this in the in the language of infinit
logic but in for finite graphs or for
finite structur in general uh
definability in this infinit logic which
I don't want to Define is the same as
being closed under this equivalence
relation for some key all
right good so so we want we're going
further so now we know about
connectivity connectivity is expressible
in inflationary fixo logic so the
probability that the fact that it has
probability one is explained by this
well of course it's explained by many
other things
right two graphs are connected two
points are connected by a path of length
two and this is true for any two points
so so it's explained by but it's saying
something so let's see what it's saying
so this is the the notion of Almost sure
explanation and and I want to make
emphasis on this because I think there
is a story to tell
here so what do I mean by an almost sure
explanation well when you want to prove
that something holds almost surely it
suffices to prove that some sufficient
condition holds almost surely right so
if you want to show that it's connected
it suffices to prove that every two
points are connected by a have a common
neighbor for
example and aary of the the colitis V
proof is that if you have a property
that is closed under this equivalence
relation and has probability
one um then there is a first order
definable explanation for it in the
sense that there's is a first order
definable property that implies it and
has probability one so it's a sufficient
condition for property p and it explains
the probability
one why is that well that's because you
can always take a skew the K extension
aums that are enough to warranty
uh uh the probability one remember
probability one happens precisely
because there is a large equivalence
class uh inside which is given by the K
extendable
graphs all right so you have
explanations like that you mean q inails
p or p inails
q
p
yeah oh
yes so here's an example all pairs have
a common neighbor is a sufficient
condition to Common activity and we
already argued that by the way this was
the second example all P have a common
neighbor has probability one well this
is an explicit explanation for
connectivity by the way it also gives
the right almost the right uh rate of
convergence but not exactly but it gives
the rate of convergence so it says this
converges to one exponentially fast so
in fact polinomial times exponentially
decaying function and Gilbert proved
that uh that this also goes of course
but not faster than that so this was the
point this is this is why I call them
explanations because they not only they
explain the fact but they also explain
more structural properties of it so I
don't know if I'll have time to to say
more about it
but now I want to say an interesting non
example so a non example is the
following so you can ask is every
property that holds almost surely
explained by some first order property
that holds
aurely just like that generally it's a
bit hard to believe right
but um maybe you can explain
hamiltonicity for example and blast and
Har prove the following negative result
it says the following so if you take a
first order definable property that is
sufficient for hamiltonicity it's a
sufficient condition to guarantee
hamiltonicity
then your screw it has probability zero
well of course the relevant note here is
that hamiltonicity has probability one
so that's
why this is saying that there is no
first order prop y that explains
hamiltonicity
and holds with probability one this is a
very nice uh negative result uh it has a
very nice construction I want to
describe it to you and it's the
following this graph in fact is very
similar to anus graph you have so you
have a k minus one click here and here
you have K minus two points so you have
one more Point inside than outside and
what this is supposed to mean is that
these points outside are connected to
everything in the click so you have a
click and all the points satellites like
this are connected to everything in the
click you can also write it in a bip
parted shape you would say you would put
the satellites on the left and the click
on the right so you connect the whole
click these guyss make an independent
set but they are fully connected to the
click so this would be the shape of noes
graph and now because there are less
satellites than the click it follows
that this is not
hamiltonian and this is the same
argument that an an had because in any
hamiltonian path um every outside vertex
has to uh be followed by an inside
vertex but there are there are more uh
you need it the other way around you
need more satellites than
the
yeah they should be K they should be
thanks the typo here
okay okay so you have more more
satellites than inside and then that
guarantees non hamiltonicity okay so
that by itself uh is not enough oh by
the way what is the strategy to prove
this I didn't say that so the strategy
will be the following we're going to
build a graph that is not hamiltonian
but that satisfies enough K extension
actions right
so and now the first order the finable
formula will be implied by some K
extension axioms so because it satisfies
enough K extension axioms it will
satisfy the formula but because it's not
hamiltonian uh so either it uh sorry
because it is implied it has probability
one so it will violate this this
condition that said it's a bit wrong so
what I want to say is the following so
the the graph will satisfy
extension
right and so it and uh and this
extension is enough to guarantee
Q because it's first order
definable right exactly so if it if you
had probability one then it would be
implied by some extension so G would
satisfy
this um but at the same time we're going
to show that g is not not
hamiltonian the G that we construct is
not going to be hamiltonian and then we
will violate this all right so this is
the
strategy but now we're not done yet we
just built an non hamiltonian graph so
how do we make it satisfy enough off
extension axioms what we do is we
basically we blow every vertex into a
potato Big Potato of R vertices and we
put random edges between any two
potatoes so we make making a random lift
of the graph this is a standard
construction it was used by Eros uh in
one of his papers to on random graphs
early papers so you have you you blow
every every vertex into a potato or
fiber or whatever and you put random
edges between all the
fibers Now The crucial property that
this has is that
um if you take any K minus one points in
this graph then there will be one
extension one common neighbor and this
will follow easily because if you take K
minus one points if you take all these K
minus one points then anybody here will
be a common neighbor the satellite and
if the K minus one points take one of
the satellites then any one inside the
click which must exist because you're
only using K minus one and you're
already using one of the satellites
anyone in the click will be a neighbor
of everything so every K minus one
points have a common neighbor and this
is enough to guarantee that the lift
will satisfy all the
extension all the extension actions
because the lift what it does is it uh
it it guarantees the extensionality but
also the non- extensionality the fact
that there is some guy that is not a
neighbor of everybody in the Same by
just a simple probabilistic counting as
we did before okay so this is a very
simple construction and it has one
consequence which is from the fact that
for by the same argument that we just
did
here uh because every if P property that
holds almost surely must be implied by
some extension axioms it also implies
the following for any ifp formula that
holds with probability one it will not
entail hamiltonicity
all right so this means that there is no
ifp formula that explains hamiltonicity
this is pretty
good I like this interesting non
negative results that hold with high
probability like this I think it's quite
powerful negative if uh in particular it
implies the inexpressibility
results none of these Logics that are CL
can exess exactly just follows directly
from
that so now comes the other question
about uh before we move to the sparse
case uh still in the dense case P equals
1 12 there is this question of how do we
compute the
probability and this has also a good
answer um fakin proof doesn't give an
answer but um the Russians proof gives
an answer and this is basically a
quantifier elimination argument that I
would had thought of giving here but I
because I want to do other things I will
refer you actually to blast and harary
paper that has a beautiful exposition of
this quantifier elimination argument and
it's very nice to read it from
there there's a second
method there's for for this is would be
for first order formula what about ifp
can you do the same can you decide what
is the probability and the original
blast gavage CA in proof
uh um was also some kind of quantifier
elimination and therefore also give an
algorithm to decide it however the
algorithm had an exponential blow up in
space and there is a reason for that as
we will
see but there is a third method method
that I have seen written anywhere but uh
it's quite simple and I want to tell you
what it is it's the following so it
works for both the only thing you need
to do is to evaluate the formula on a k
extend on some K extendable graph uh for
K large enough namely K bigger than the
number of variables of the
formula and the reason this works is
that uh well it's the usual one that if
if it has probability one then it has
this uh equivalence class
inside and constru the yeah
so okay so it's clear it works for the
same reason that the 01 low holds it's
enough to evaluate it like this and this
requires the G extendable graph and well
you can find one by
just throwing I mean coins at random you
with high probability you get a k
extendable graph but even explicit
constructions exist
and these explicit constructions are
exponentially big only so 2 to the K
it's not too bad and uh so also another
by again Andreas gave a a proof that the
pale graphs the classic pale graphs
actually satisfy the K extendable
property for uh so the pale graph has
two to the K vertices approximately two
to the PO polinomial in K and it
satisfies all the K extension
actions there is a more recent uh
explicit construction that is purely
combinatorial and doesn't use the number
theory that is
behind um the
P another thing to say is that these
graphs are explicit enough that this
algorithm will be competitive to the
algorithms that come out of here in
particular the algorithm can be done in
polinomial space even though the graph
is exponentially
big it's exponentially big in K you
because it's explicit you can actually
run through all vertices and check the
quantifiers and also the edge relation
can be checked in polinomial space
itself so in fact we can do it in
polinomial space for first order logic
because evaluating first order formula
on a on
a on a structor is a polinomial space
algorithm and
um a log space attribute log space of
exponential is is a polinomial space and
for this one you get an expon enial time
algorithm and in fact there is you
cannot do better than that because uh in
the case of first or the logic Grand Jan
realize that it's not only ppace but
even PE space
complete the P space harness was not
what Grand that's right membership in
space because the p space was from stock
M as we saw here right yeah ppace
hardness just follows from the theory of
equality so you don't need even relation
but he had a different Al he had an
alter Pol time
algorithm different from these three
that I just said thank
you the exponential time completeness
was proved by Blas gich and Coen and
this requires actually no the hardness
is
again could follow for free from even
though this is not how they do it it
could follow from free from the theory
of
equality all
right okay so so now I want to talk
about the sparse case this was the
random uh graph with constant Edge
probability and this was the case that
Gilbert was interested in and here I
want to look at these two cases which
are by
far some of the most studied cases in
random graph literature this one in
particular is the one studied by Eros
and Reni in 19 59 the first
paper so notice the number of edges you
will have an average for if you have C
Over N because you have n Square edges
you have a linear number of edges in
this case on average and here you
get n log n edges
plus uh linear
term all right so let's focus on this
part which is the this is actually the
threshold of connectivity and it's a
very interesting thing so we think of c
as a constant and then going as to
Infinity so
here um the basic tool here is again in
addition to the inclusion Exclusion
Principle first and second moment
another basic tool is the POS
Paradigm and again I want to say that uh
so maybe this is the right time to say
that all these arguments of 01 laws uh
they all followed from just Computing
the probability of the extension actions
and that we only use their first moment
just right it was very simple
computation so what this is explaining
is that when you compute the probability
of a first order formula that explains
why you are always re resorting to to
the first moment because of all that's
the only thing you need right so this is
the power of these meta theorems that
say that all first order formulas
Computing each probability even
approximating it just follows from first
moment so I think this is of value this
sort of theorems the sort of statements
are of value for to understand what's
happening so now I want to claim that in
this other context of sparse graphs but
the only other thing you need at least
for first order formula is the Quant
paradig and indeed you look at books and
and papers and this is what they use all
the time
right when they look at first order
properties okay so what's the pon
Paradigm you have a bunch of uh random
variables 01 Valu and they have some
small expectation Lambda Over N you
should think of Lambda as a constant so
these are rare
events and now the conditions of the
poson Paradigm this is an informal
statement it says that if you have if
this events or these random variables
are nearly independent and nearly I'm
not defining and N is large then this
sum is going to be approximately poson
it's distributed like a poson random
variable with parameter
Lambda now nearly independent
uh uh I'm not defining but I don't need
to Define it it just means the intuitive
thing that the probability of the
product is close to the probability of
the joint event of all the events
happening
all right and so what is a poson
distribution uh well what does it mean
to approximately B poson it means
approximately B poson so the probability
of being high is just the poson
distribution and this can also be made
for made formal uh this is the poson
Paradigm let's give one example which is
illustrative and it's the same example
as before all points have at least one
neighbor and so happens that the
probability of that is this beautiful
quantity um
so how do we prove that so let's look at
the event for Fix N and U the event that
U does not have neighbors and this is
again this quantity it's one minus P to
the rest of neighbors by
Independence and now this if you look at
the probability the expression you plug
it into this p and you use this usual
approximation when X is small which is
the case because p is M remember n goes
to Infinity then you plug this in and
you get this quantity
all right so these events are red events
and you think of this as Lambda you have
Lambda Over N so you have 01 random
variables whether it have a common uh it
has a nebor or
not yeah so you can apply the pon
Paradigm and the near Independence is
not obvious but it's true so you can
apply the pon Paradigm to these
indicator random variables with these
parameters so you get that the
probability of not having Neighbors
is distributed like poson and the
probability of Aon being zero is this
quantity so Paradigm gives you what you
want did you when you were talking about
some par did you make explicit what you
mean by near Independence no I said
explicitly that I don't want to say what
it is sorry it means the intuitive thing
that
the the probability of the probability
of several variables being one is almost
equal to the product of the
probabilities that's enough if you have
that uniformly then it's enough
to all right so here is an amazing
convergence law for first order logic I
call it amazing because the first time I
see it uh well the statement like this
is not that amazing what comes next is
the amazing part so the property says
that if you have a first order definable
property and you look at this varing
probabilities of this shape with
parameterized by this
C which is the C remember I mean this
par this is the case of Eros Ry this is
the one they were looking at then the
probability exists
moreover the probability is a finite sum
of terms of this kind where Lambda is e
to the minus
C okay so this is quite impressive uh
you describe exactly how they look the
probabilities and so when I first saw it
I say wow how do they do that this is
for the formula is quite complicated and
they can do this for any formula but but
then the beautiful thing is that the
proof is very Illuminating and once you
understand the proof then it's no longer
amazing it's very the most natural thing
it's really not I mean this is one of
the examples where proofs really explain
things I mean it's not I this students
don't really believe this right why do
you do proofs we don't need proofs I
just believe you
but that's I find it quite annoying look
at the proof and you'll understand it
better all right so so at the end I want
to give a sketch of this proof we have
time but now we want to go back to this
notion of explanations so do we have
explanations here
again so here is an example of an
explanation look at the property some
point has no neighbors so an isolated
point now this implies non-connectivity
right if you have an isolated point it's
not connected and the probability of uh
having an isolated point is one minus
the probability of not having isolated
point which we already computed it was
that and turns out that this happens to
be exactly the probability of
non-connectivity and this is from the OS
Ry paper so this very simple uh
sufficient
condition I'm not saying that it
explains non-connectivity it's too
simple but it explains the the shape of
the the probability and these are fine
amazing so the question
is it explains the lower
bound uh and it doesn't explain the
upper
bound or does it I mean if you look at
the
proof of Eros Ren and it's very easy to
read actually this paper it's very well
written fantastic paper H there is
something going on there that might be
possible to to explain also the upper
bound maybe not by a first order
condition but by something else and this
is
open this is one of the questions I want
to raise in this
talk
so let's look at now the the linear case
you have linear number of edges and
expectation and we look also at we look
also at uh these things of
explanations so Lynch had another
convergence law and this was before
actually the thas Spencer conversion law
and it says that if you are in this
regime then the probability exists
moreover the probability and as a
function of C right it exists and it
must be a function of C it's the only
parameter happening
there and the formula of course so as a
function of C it is a continuous
function made of plus minus time e to
the X so the exponential C and real
constants actually rational
constants
so so this is even more amazing I would
say right you have these amazing shapes
so here is one example that things that
can happen in the first order world at
this regime there is some triangle this
property I made up uh I cooked up a
little bit from Spencer's book to have
the shape that I wanted so the property
is there is some triangle whose vertices
all have some neighbor outside the
triangle that itself has no other
neighbors okay it doesn't matter whether
it makes sense or not what I wanted is
to have a property that has uh this
probability and in fact you can make any
ups and any as many ups and downs as you
like by alternating
quantifiers so in fact the probability
of this property is this uh strange
looking function or not so strange
actually it's very
natural let's go to more explanations
now now at this level C Over N can we
explain more things so there is this
very famous uh business of sharp
thresholds right so let's look at the
property of non-re colorability
it is known that there is there are
constant CNL CL and CU so that if you
look at a random graph with
approximately uh C * n
edges and C is below this constant then
the graph is almost surely not three
colorable it's almost surely three
colable of course so so three
colorability has probability one non-
three colorability has probability zero
and if it's dense it's dense Beyond this
constant then it's almost surely non
three colorable and this is natural
right the more edges you put the more
likely it is to be non three colorable
so you have this uh you have this shape
of
probability so the limiting probability
is
zero for non three colorability
up to some constant c l and after some
constanty U we have probability one the
limiting probability of non 3ol
ability
okay here in the middle it's a bit fuzzy
what's happening but it's conject that
there is a constant so in fact this
reaches here and up to here you have
zero and beyond that you have uh one
this is conector it's not yet proved
that there is such a
constant anyway so what I'm asking now
is whether you can explain something
from this
picture in the sense of explanations
right like we explained connectivity we
explain the shape can we explain
something from here and it turns out
that for by first order logic you cannot
explain it and there is very simple
argument it's the following it's based
on this conversion law of
Lynch so the question is can you explain
for example this thing up here that you
have once when you're dense Enough by
the way some lose bounds if you care but
it's not really
important so for for our discussion it's
not important for the theorems
themselves are important so here's a
simple observation um if you have a
first order definable property that
implies non-tol ability
so it's a sufficient condition for non
three colorability that supposedly is
going to to explain that and it doesn't
has probability zero so it's and this is
very simple from the 01 law by the way
recall that you have probability one
right beyond that so here's the proof
it's very simple by Lynch conversion law
this thing the limiting probability is a
real analytic function of C was made of
exponentials plus times minus no
divisions but but uh we have zeros
here everywhere here
so so because we have zeros and we have
entailment we're assuming that this
entails that then this is zero so this
probability must be zero at all this uh
interval but then it must be zero
everywhere because analytic functions
the zero set of an analytic function
cannot have uh I mean must have zero
measure this is a known fact of analytic
functions one variable analytic
functions so this doesn't have uh
measure zero so it must be the whole
thing I mean non-trivial analytic
functions have have uh zero sets of
measure zero so that's it and this is
using Lynch proof and I was wondering
how I would prove this directly without
knowing this structor of the limiting
probabilities and I was not able to do
it at least in the few days that I've
been preparing to talk maybe it's doable
but I don't know
so this is something I wanted to to
share with you and maybe I want to
claim I mean some of you may know that
uh few years ago I studied random 3 CNF
formulas So Random three CNF formulas so
these are CNF formulas generated at
random this is a model of random
structures that is not random graphs but
and there what I proved is that if you
the random 3 formulas also have this
kind of behavior if you have a linear
number of closes below some threshold
then it's almost surely
satisfiable and Beyond some threshold
it's almost surely
unsatisfiable so what I proved in that
in 2002 is that uh there is no
explanation for that fact that is
expressible in data
log right and I
claim without proof that it also holds
for three colorability so I think I can
go through the proof that I did in 2002
to show that this result also holds for
data locks right here so there is no
data lock definable property that
explains non-3 colorability
that explains this part of three
colorability however it still open since
then to extend this to fixo logic to
inationary fix Point logic and I think
this should be doable but nobody really
looked at the problem so what what L had
some papers on infinitary Logics right
uhhuh
did it cover this case no
95 it covered even even sparer case yes
it didn't cover the C over
then all
right so so now I have 10 minutes
left so I had this part of discussion
and then the proof the schedu of the
proof of the of Lynch Not Lynch but Toma
Spencer convergence FLW
I don't know maybe five minutes on each
let's see okay so so I see so somehow
this this business of 01 laws and random
structures and logic
uh I mean it went very fast in the
beginning but then it started stalling
and somehow now it's not very active and
I think there are directions that can be
followed and they are interesting and
people should look more at that in
particular these explanations business I
think think we could say something more
about it so let me say three concrete
things that we could try to look at for
example on syntax there's been a lot of
work on trying to go beyond first order
Beyond fix Point Logic for example
second order logic there is um beautiful
work by Fon and collaborators on on
second order logic however there's uh
whole class of properties that are not
covered and that random graph theorists
are very interested in which are
properties that involve counting sizes
of things like for example what is the
size of the largest connected component
what is the um yeah the size of the
largest click in the graph and so on and
so forth what is the chromatic number
when the chromatic number is not bounded
by a constant like three for all these
things uh you could do by throwing in
counting quantifiers in your logic but
then very quickly you kill any
possibility of 01 laws or conversion
laws so the challenge here is to come up
with design language I mean we need to
design some language that explains the
that that gives some that that is useful
for graph theorists that explains what
the graph theorists are doing the random
graph theorist are doing in particular
here is an
interesting difficult question
but this is the kind of things I'm I'm
I'm thinking
of would be very nice to find some kind
of logical limit law that explains the
lower bound on the diagonal ramom
so Eros proved it was the first use of
the probabilistic method that
uh uh the the number of vertices you
need to find a a k click or a k
independent set in a graph must be
exponentially big right and this was
proved by choosing a random graph and
then checking that it doesn't have uh
such
things so so it is proved in fact almost
all Gra satisfy the property that Eros
needed and however the the problem with
that is that the size of the graph is
something like 2 to the K and you're
looking at clicks and independent sets
of size
K so this means that if you take this
for n then the sizes of the clicks and
in the I think it's something like K
over two but it doesn't really matter
something like so it means that if you
take n for the size of the structure
then you're looking at clicks and
independent sets of size log which is
not something you can say in any natural
logic that we work on but maybe we can
throw in some device that allows us to
talk about log n so this is one question
that uh might be possible to to do by
designing a proper language I think this
is an important question because for
example we don't know explicit
graphs that are uh that are of the kind
that there those show to
exist so maybe the logic could could
give something on that now about sharp
thresholds um okay so what there is this
fre good theorem famous fre good theorem
that says that in the particular case of
three colorability
um it says the following it doesn't say
that there is a constant what it says is
that there is a
function so this is a specialized fre
Goods theorem is specialized to three
colorability it is a function so that if
your
probability is smaller than P of n
smaller than
that then you're almost surely three
colorable and if the probability is
bigger than that 1 plus Epsilon sorry uh
over
n c star n Over N then almost surely
you're non three
colorable and what we would really like
is to have a constant here not uh uh not
a function of n so what this mean this
function we know this function is
bounded by two
constants so so it must so the question
is whether it converges or whether it
goes crazy like that so we cannot
conclude that there is a constant
because this we don't know how it looks
like and the reason this is like that is
because FR Goods theorem is not uniform
in N it for every n it does a separate
argument and it is based on properties
of of the hyper Cube
and of uh of the mention n and there is
no way to do it uniformly and this is
calling for a uniform proof because it's
you're looking at not an arbitrary
property but three-color ability which
is quite definable it's quite simple and
quite nice this 3 CNF you would solve
the problem with the exact thres right
that's what you asking yeah it's the
same as three colorability there's
recent results by Sly and others for K
CNF where they get a sharp
threshold but K has to be large so for k
equals 3 their methods don't
work but in general this would be an
idea to to try to make this this
inherently non-uniform argument try to
make it uniform and and get rid of this
annoying uh situations all right so
about
explanations uh so explain why first
order properties appear as necessary or
sufficient conditions depending on which
context you are so often and there is
another example which is the
hamiltonicity it happens to be this is
the probability and then a first order
property aligns very much with this
probability anyway so this I don't want
to say a lot more so now maybe in the
last three or four minutes I can tell
you about this amazing proof and finish
and finish there so in fact when you see
the proof it this is how it has to be
done of course so the proof this is from
Spencer's book uh strange logic of
random graphs or something like
that the first step there are four steps
I believe you list as many Almost sure
properties as you can you throw in so
what are the Almost sure properties of
the random
graph at this at this density and this
is very well understood so for example
for every fixed K there are no K points
that induce K plus one edges or more so
in particular every finite subset is
unicyclic it has only one
cycle there are R cycles of length k for
any R and K there are R Points of degree
K all these things are true for every
fixed R and K and these are first order
properties um there do not exist K and K
Prime Cycles at this fixed distance so
if you fix the distance and sizes of
Cycles then you cannot find that in fact
I was thinking last night that this is a
consequence of this this is actually
believe this is a consequence because
you have two cycles in in a in a bonded
size set but this one is not a uh yeah
this one is not a consequence it says
that you cannot find two degree K and
this is exactly the degree K points at
distance D these are wellknown
properties and also you cannot find a
degree cave vertex close to a k cycle
okay so let TB the set of all these
axioms this is like the part of the
Almost sure Theory now let's describe
the countable models of this how do they
look like and this we need to
drawing so from these aums that I
described this is going to look
something like this so you're going to
have cycles of all
lengths and branching from this you'll
have infinitely branching
trees so these are infinite infinite
degrees
branching from the Cycles you have
infinitely branching trees and these are
components they are separated they don't
merge and you will also have vertices of
degree
K whose neighbors will have infinite
degree uh infinitely like that and this
for every K so they get K they get K
plus one and so
on this will follow also
from uh from this one there are no two
things I mean this these actions
guarantee that the the countable models
are like this and then maybe you also
have two more things one is you may have
uh threes of infinite
degree and also isolated points this is
the models all look like
that okay so we describ the countable
models and now what we want to identify
what is missing to make it into a
complete Theory and what I claim that
the only thing you need to make it it
into a complete theory is count how many
isolated points you
have and this you can do by a by a
pebble game argument and it's not
terribly
difficult so and now you notice that
this additional axioms which complete
the theory so any addition if you add
any of these you have the theory and you
add this this is complete so and this
completions are
incompatible because if you have I
isolated vertices you don't have I prime
if I prime is from one and also they
cover all the
possibilities okay this is because you
have this Plus on distribution of for
the degrees the number of vertices of
degree or isolated vertices and now you
conclude that the probability must be
then a finite sum of the additional aoms
that make f a consequence which must be
non empty right or could be empty if
it's if it's totally false for example
and this follows from a simple argument
just
some kind of a simple limiting argument
and
compactness and then in the end we need
to use here something that looks like
the mark of inequality the problem is
that it's in reverse and the point is
that here we're using that these are
incompatible conditions or these are the
joint events and therefore this will
actually work the loss will come from
the fact that this is an almost short
sentence this almost short sentence you
can forget about it U by some small
error that you're making and and then
you get what you wanted so the
probability is approximated by a finite
sum and this is a finite sum of these
properties and these properties you know
the probabilities they are the
probabilities that come from the Plus on
distribution so this is the proof and it
had to be a bit fast because I'm out of
time but if you want I want I can go a
bit uh slower at some other time thank
you very
much question okay just a question the
previous slide why is t+ 5 I
complete well you need to do a pebble
Pebble game argument to show that if you
fix if you have exactly the same number
of isolated points then the rest of the
structure is is looks the same because
in fact these guys you have infinitely
many you have not only one cycle of theg
K you have infinitely many cycles of the
g k so in this part you just play a
pebble game and the action is
guaranteeing that the parts that you
could distinguish you
cannot it's not a difficult
argument so in random graph Theory over
like I guess the last decade it's been
very fashionable to consider random
graph models like preferential
attachment and things that have power
law the the distributions and so forth
so do we know any Z1 law in that context
yeah so there's a paper by Jame James
Lynch licks maybe 5 years ago or a bit
more and he considers their power low
graphs so graph some models that have
this power low condition I don't know
exactly what he proves but I know that
he has studied this
thing yeah so the other thing is the
question your question goes a bit in the
line of whether this graph model
something and maybe we should make them
usually the way I approach this is I
don't really want to be modeling
problems uh because I think of this as
building blocks for other things like I
think random graph theory has
been has been useful in other things
that are not just the random graph
itself so to develop techniques for
analyzing other processes and this
logical approach explains that
so could explain that so this would be
nice okay
well let's thank all
again